après les européennes et avant les
régionales ce vent de rébellion au sein
du MoDem un conseil national s tenu ce
matin à huclos François Baayou a été
sommé de donner davantage la parole à
ceux qui l'entourent de lancer une vaste
rénovation du Parti démocrate Caroline
leinter Robin
teboule appel à la grande rénovation du
MoDem après la débacle des européennes
certains militants et cadres du parti
voir rouge ils sont environ 200 à avoir
signé cette lettre ouverte aux
dirigeants du mouvement démocrate en
ligne de mire leur chef de fil François
Baayou le modemme n'est pas que François
Baayou le modème ce sont des cadres ce
sont des militances ce sont des idées ce
sont des valeurs qui dépassent
évidemment la seule personne de François
baayrou ce que l'on veut c'est d'avoir
les moyens de faire passer ces idées
dans la société on a besoin de
porte-parole on a besoin de gens qui
identifie qui s'identifie au modem on a
besoin de gens qui peuvent être
identifiés personnalisation excessive a
tour de son leader campagne trop tourné
vers la présidentielle de nombreux
militants disent stop dans leur courrier
il réclam la mise en place d'un conseil
stratégique la nomination d'une dizaine
de secrétaires nationaux et d'au moins
deux porte-paroles dans l'intérêt même
de notre président et de ses ambitions
il faut qu'il y ait derrière lui un
mouvement qui soit puissant mais qui
soit aussi multiforme qui remontre toute
la la diversité la richesse de de cette
équipe la direction du parti n'apprécie
que modérément ce grand déballage le
député européen Jean-Luc benamias juge
l'initiative destructrice quant à
Marielle de sarnz numéro 2 du MoDem elle
estime que le parti n'a plus le choix je
sais que le Conseil national va prendre
ces ces décisions qui vont aller dans le
bon sens et qui vont au fond démontrer
que oui François Baou a a su
écouter comprendre et entendre les
adhérents et ça c'est très prometteur il
va falloir redresser la bar plus vite en
vue des régionales de 2010 le nouveau
centre partenaire de l'UMP prétend avoir
accueilli depuis juin 1 milliers de
déçus du
MoDem